lng or liquefied natural gas imports
from the us have increased substantially
in the eu in recent years right now
europe has 34 lng terminals but not one
of them is in germany that's about to
change now
construction on germany's first lng port
in brunswick is starting soon
transporting and handling lng is a
complicated matter for example before
transport the lng has to be liquefied by
being cooled down to minus 162 degrees
here's an animated version of how it
will look it would be germany's first
direct access point for lng suppliers
from qatar algeria and the us
the location was selected strategically
pipelines starting here lead to all
points in germany
we would like to use the lng as fuel and
also distribute it from here we're
ideally located on the elba close to the
port of hamburg but we also have access
to the kiel canal which gives us access
to the baltic states and the
scandinavian countries
at the moment liquefied natural gas only
plays a nominal role in germany's energy
mix around 2000 trucks registered in
germany run on lng the fuel has so far
been supplied by other european ports in
neighboring countries belgium and the
netherlands
energy expert sebastian timmerback feels
it's unnecessary for germany to build
its own lng station
in the near land in rotterdam in the
netherlands and also in zayburger in
belgium large lng import terminals
already exist which are only running at
about 50 capacity
they could be used for any additional
supply
will the new lng station pay for itself
demand for lng will be growing in the
coming years the port operator is
certain of that and the port could
become the future site of a new
environmentally friendly energy source
hydrogen
with our potential customer rweag
we would like to find out to what extent
an lng terminal is a building block in
the development of a hydrogen
infrastructure
if they're right it would be a stroke of
luck for the new port and the investment
would pay off for decades to come
you